here he is north korean supreme leader
hadn't been seen in public for nearly
three weeks
which led to some pretty wild
speculation about his health
new footage released by state media put
all that to bed
kim jong-un apparently hearty and hail
and certainly not so fearful for his
health to abstain from his beloved
cigarettes
but most importantly very much in charge
as he cut the ribbon on a fertilizer
factory
his disappearance is still unexplained
though kim's
self-professed friend president trump
teased a potential answer north korean
leader just surfaced
at a fertilizer plant in north korea uh
do you know about this anything you can
tell us
i'd rather not comment on it yet kim
jong-un uh will
have something to say about it at the
appropriate time
i don't want to talk about it in the
year or so since the failed summit
between trump and kim in vietnam
north korea has been readjusting its
strategy the dictator had been doubling
down on propaganda
like this at the same time as increasing
the frequency of weapons tests
but nothing caught the world's attention
like simply not being there
this was his last appearance until now
on april the 11th
the possibility of his demise the lack
of a clear successor
could have been deeply destabilizing for
international affairs
especially because relations between the
two big powers for the stake in this
china and the us are at their worst in
decades
his health is very poor right and i
think this sort of brought that to the
fore right i mean he's seriously
overweight you can tell just from
looking at him
we know he smokes and drinks a great
deal he's had hypertension we believe
he's had gout
at some point his very indulgent
lifestyle will catch up with him and
because north korea is a monarchy that
raises questions of succession
even if he's healthy now the issues that
we're concerned about will pop up in the
next five
10 15 years or something like that
unless he dramatically changes
some analysts had suggested that kim's
sister kim yo-jong
could be a successor her role had been
made more prominent over the last few
months
and she was front and center here today
ready to lend a hand passing the
scissors
north korea is a dynastic dictatorship
and so the question of succession is
never
far away but for today at least it can
be postponed
tom cheshire sky news beijing